ma ora passata c'è sempre la droga io ai
comitato non
ha mangiato solo gli spaghetti nessuno
può farlo muto malata acquista porno
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi ben tornato in una puntata
di cucina buttare
tornati e siamo contentissimi cinema
verità c'è seppur è tempo di dire ciao
c'è un cafone e cafone di merda la
puntata della giornata interessante
perché dopo due anni riga due anni
quanto sono 365 merci per due 730 giorni
migliori una ricetta che mi arriva
spesso nei bienni per fortuna che avrò
ricevuto digiuno non sto scherzando ci
sono sempre detto no col calcio perché è
veramente abominevole di che si tratta
oggi faremo ieri spaghetti ragazza che è
stata criticata da gordon ramsay
vediamole insieme partiamo bene
prendesti spaghetti di infila lì lì
rosola all'interno di sti cosi le
felicissima a getti genti spaghetti nel
senso che rilanci via f poi cui mette
una spezia in sala peperoni cipolle
caramelle e spiega che il motivo per cui
lo fa non è perché quel brand che sta
dando i soldi unica motivazione io posso
dare a questo video ma perché in questo
modo rilasceranno la loro dolcezza ma
perché si scioglieranno 12 non si
sciolgono questa passata beni lei mi fa
rivedere le caramelle ha fatto apposta
una cosa assurda per farsi pubblicità
cosa sono delle pantegane tante cane o
detto svelate volta che lo avrei fatto
non era pronto ma adesso sono pronto
partiamo col preparativo spaghetti
macinato mozzarella per pizza peperone
verde peperone giallo cipolla spezia
enemy linee passata di pomodoro che tra
parentesi sotto tutto che ho detto
perché si chiama puma roll issima che
nel nome sicuramente un prodotto
proveniente dallo teutonico proprio che
brand che è lo sponsor di questo video
che sarà sì lo sponsor di questo video
non è vero akiva di iniziare a vomitare
fondamentale altra cosa e serve
artigiani per pulizia poche ma certo poi
dipende tu con cosa va con fondi la tua
figlia
non so bene come fare dividiamo in due
come se fosse dico una ciocca ok più o
meno uguali vedo che lei fa se in questa
parte mi sfugge oltremodo avete presente
internet perché ero in venti le cose
cioè amica nemica spiega come si fa il
sushi è come se lo fai silenzio grande
detti sì non sei nella posizione per per
parlare con voi in che posizione siete
invece ragazzi 90 ok abbiamo molte cose
in comune vi siete nella posizione di
premere iscriviti a questo canale
segnerò sta merda ma voi un piccolo
pollice nel tentato non potete mettere
al pollice in su per
[Musica]
si stanno ribellando tutto questo è vero
bisogna essere molto sul wii delicati
abbiamo ste 2 werder se una pillolina
mio terrore che si sfaldino ma non ci
mette nulla olio qualcosa non niente se
fosse appena sopra il mio terrore invece
di aiuti di ridurre cosi dicono dei
cachi 16 bello è 2 e siccome siamo
sicuri che sia per l'induzione è sì lo
abbiamo già usata lui c'entra stato si
sta rifiutando anche il formello
pazienza dai ci vediamo abbiamo fino
all'esordio i ragazzi usano un
adattatore ma porta così a un adattatore
non è che sia molto contento ogni
valtellino adattatore parte la
produzione di spielberg
[Musica]
e fa questo suono ma induzione vengono
meglio peggio secondo voi di alieni
sulla terra sento un odore rivoltante di
barkan ce l'ha sentita oddio di coca
allontanate che potrebbe essere il
radioattivo spendi spendi spendi spendi
sta bruciando qualcosa ho visto uscire
del fumo considera io mai comitato miei
sono tenuti colati deve servire magari
mi scrivete nei commenti come usare
questo adattatore per favore
ora senti l'odore siamo tornati dalla
pista scusi la ricetta queste intanto lo
tolgo e lo piazzo quale decide vivere
lambo cruda la carne poi tanto si cucina
il forno che cavolo la cucio
vct siete contenti che c'è il forno
incanto si dai l'abbiamo vista passa per
voi cari non li hai utilizzato la prima
volta più che sia tutto il genere
bisogna attaccare la spina attaccato il
forno america
il forno
[Risate]
malata chi sta porno invece far
simpatico eto'o sta facendo le scale e
ci vuole tempo
male che cavolo ma allora posto mondo
tanto ci vuole sono già spuntati gino
che una volta non li faccio più raga
santo dio
sento che quello veramente hattori hanzo
lo ha fatto questo coltello è assurda
buttiamo dissapori che possono piacere
ci vuole buona un po meglio per il tuo
interlocutore ma che dobbiamo farlo in a
vita tu sei fidanzato giammarco un
monaco asceta l'unica persona che
vorrebbe [ __ ] predator ma non hanno
nessuna quindi comunque ragazzi questo
coltello e assurdi harris e guardi per
tre tori invece che guardare la gallery
questo coltello al sud il tacco tac tac
posso dire che ha perse tutta l'italia
evita anche nel momento stesso in cui
abbiamo tirati fuori dalla scatola prima
cioè supermercati gianmarco che va a
fare la spesa a tutti quanti che tremano
gli spaghetti nome
commessi mi guardano con occhio
guardingo vorrei farle qualche domanda
su questi cereali
certo certo ragazzo c'è sempre la droga
è un'opzione migliore non ci sono più le
droghe di una volta a conoscere la
differenza tra il peperone giallo e
verde si uno giallo ne perderà cambia
qualcosa dentro forse meglio di maturità
più saggio meno saggio stato secondo me
a improvvisa improvvisa totalmente sia
qualcosa si vive ronnie ce lo faccia
sapere sapere che pokémon e dal banfield
bravi che cos'è
che accozzaglia posso dirlo aggiunge lo
spezia si spezzi per l'arrosto
ma non c'e poca secondo me si offre in
cucina da qui si ossa perché finiamo
come scheletri e qui visto che non
abbiamo usato abbastanza da sentire
questo rumore non è un salvadanaio sono
delle denunce che ci arriverà laghetti
spaghetti dice di mettere delle
caramelle che lei mette solamente perché
la paga non deve essere rispettoso verso
parola e dicono che in questo modo
rilasceranno dolce ma lei che ha
studiato per uscire con questa fase
ingegnere nucleare
un barone
almeno copri tutto è come quando metti
la polvere sotto il tappeto io sono così
a dieta anche questa roba comunque mi fa
gola non ci facciamo mancare niente
mozzarelli in realtà potevi benissimo
buttarla in caciara e fare una specie di
ragù grezzo ma voi nessuno avrebbe
parlato di lei qual è il cibo più
schifoso vedevano ha lanciato io una
roba fatta molto di recente cosa la
carbonara dolce
scrivono che mangiano la vita io il
balut a pechino express il gustoso
ultimo giro di formaggio che ho messo un
botto ma trasborderà tutto la punisce
con l'anfratto doppio
[Musica]
220 gradi per
a questo si scioglie tutto sarà un
delirio a meno che non entri dentro
dubito sperando che poi quella teglia
sia la forma si
può scoprire mandiamo
di partire con 30 minuti io ho già
cominciato a sentire l'odore che non mi
convince molto scappiamo
ragazzi è passata mezz'ora dentro al
forno
ecco la precisione
che succede è uscita una nube di fuoco
presidenti che a me anche fa pure un po
gola vista così
addio padre al turn over e non
delle correnti diverte a sentire quindi
addio mamma mia presento tantissimo ho
dei dubbi legati a 200.000 cose la prima
come fanno a cucinarsi gli spaghetti
dentro la seconda che fine hanno fatto
le caramelle forse si sono sciolti nella
mente il fatto vale davvero così
preoccupato da un assaggio ragazzi
dall'orso quanto ma non ce la fanno e
pinza a prenderla è troppo grande raga
nemmeno si piega questa pasta è
palesemente crudo
partiamo dal lato parte più esterna sono
impianti traghetti dentro non ci sono
caramelle
mi piace sono delle fine ci piace a lui
ha già fatto e l'espressione un po
incerta o quel soia cesar già ecco vedi
esattamente quella orrenda non rari
bieler gli alimenti base non sono
sbagliati ma fa proprio contro la logica
della cucina ma te piace quindi non so
sempre cento facendo massaggio ancora
più crudele dell'interno
perché per esempio a me la pasta al
dente piacevano assordante per sé e per
l'assaggio anche selezione rocco ma che
hai scelto gianmarco è quello che più
può tirar fuori l'odio ti ringrazio per
l'opportunità da guglielmo è veramente
cruda pensa che sia sushi come la
tentazione molto bella provo a essere
bravo ok e mettete tutto in mezzo mi
cacciano la bocca del sottomarino da
seguire il signore
ma manager ma con sun mangiato non fai
vedere il fazzoletto se non hai messo il
boccone di ravo chi piace però senti gli
spaghetti vuoi morire devo provare devo
ritrovare l'altro e di che un piatto che
si riprova rimane comunque un piatto
proponibile per shining
ha baciato solo gli spaghetti aveva
detto non mangiare gli spaghetti ma qual
è la coordinazione pensiero movimento
esattamente non è male vuoi chiedere che
scusa ghetti no non lo mangio anche i
tre bocconi e lo chiedono il mio
matrimonio così da avere subito il
divorzio che serve la dentiera io vi
prego quando ne proponete queste cose su
instagram o anche sotto ai video mi
mandate i link mettetevi sempre una mano
sul cuore non li butto ste cose nelle
mani pian piano nelle pause pranzo in
ogni pausa pranzo ore che fossero sun è
qualcosa che mi dà il sorriso non la
merda prova miglior dare una cosa prezzo
felice
non lo so tipo la karbon a francese io
mi sarei mangiato prevede che salverà
comunque deciso che se mai dovessi
raggiungere di quelle forme dove voglia
mercificare un po il mio corpo può farlo
nudo va in cucina nudo cucina butta
caloroso col grembiulino lo scempio per
i nostri occhi quindi sperare che non
succeda mai insomma vabbè ragazzi siamo
grati alla fine niente ci vediamo
domenica prossima con un'altra ricetta
ciao ciao ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]